hey what's up everybody welcome to the
are you garbage comedy podcast
yes gang hit that subscribe button to
make sure that you get the episodes as
they come out welcome to another
exciting edition of ru garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley hey everybody out
there and welcome back to everybody's
favorite new podcast this is ru garbage
to show what we sit down with your
favorite comedians and find if they grew
up classy or if their complete piece of
[ __ ]
I'm your host aids Foley coming at you
on an absolutely beautiful day here at
gas digital studios in the East Village
of New York City
my co-host coming at you from right next
to me oh the brains behind the operation
he put the whole thing together ladies
and gentlemen let me remind you the next
time you're reaching for a best pal make
it a Kippy this kids alright give it up
for mr. Kevin James Orion everybody hey
gang happy to be here this is very weird
to do this in person with everybody I
don't know where to look I'm the closest
I've done this with Foley in the past
three rows been like 120 guys thanks so
much for listen this is [ __ ] awesome
first show gas and gas digital studios
we are [ __ ] excited if you haven't
already please go make sure you rate
review subscribe on iTunes the full
video is it will be available on YouTube
you can subscribe there as well and also
sign up for gas digital network use code
a yg save a couple of bucks and let us
what our beat you know what I mean
also we're currently in the [ __ ]
charts right now buddy yes sir
top 103 103 with a bullet my friends
I'll bring that back to 120 not show off
your keep a low profile give it one more
album I [ __ ] that up gang that voice
you're here we cannot be more excited to
have our incredibly special guest here
with today first one in the studio we've
been friends since [ __ ] Jump Street
off the streets of [ __ ] Philly
as an active this gentleman has appeared
in sex drugs and rock and roll wait what
are you doing Law and Order Special
Victims Unit of course they'll Co proper
you've seen him on Comedy Central Just
for Laughs new faces his podcast a fair
one you can check out he is absolutely
fantastic he's a complete piece he's
he's wearing painters shorts in the
studio like he's just [ __ ] got the
shed done no joke these are these are
homemade jean shorts it's the only shirt
I wear in the summer because I didn't
think they were Calvin Klein I got
swampy I can't wear khakis ladies and
gentlemen the pride of Delaware County
give it the [ __ ] up for mr. Tommy Poe
thanks for having me boys I'm excited
for you happy to be here buddy you were
you were you were on the short list when
we first started this thing yeah and we
asked this this guy tries the [ __ ]
big diamond Tommy hey buddy can you do
it oh yeah no it was like the episode
two or three and I'll tell you it
started before I answer this [ __ ]
question I saw you post a video we're
talking about how an above-ground pool
is garbage and it lit me up I was
furious I'm like that is [ __ ] royalty
who was [ __ ] on an above-ground pool my
best friend growing up his parents had
an above-ground pool and I thought his
dad was like an oil tycoon a prince
right who can afford a [ __ ] buck now
boom we got whip another private jet
hidden huh do my debt my mom sent me
these uh these photos home to my Queens
apartment and I have a Polaroid of us
getting we used to get wet by the hose
in the backyard yeah cuz she wouldn't
take us to the pool just squirt
and I'm nude so it's me and my two weeks
ago it's [ __ ] unbelievable
above-ground pool the [ __ ] balls you
know we're bit so there I get it they're
great they're fantastic about their
trash it's like we didn't know one
there's nobody with the money for
in-ground pool they got an above-ground
pool they're trash you like the cool
water you dope those [ __ ] in-ground
pools they get too hot by July it's like
a bathtub well I thought he was the
quarantine was gonna be like two weeks
sure I'd rather do it in person because
I like you know and then the the zoom
call kind of [ __ ] really function at the
time
ah ah well we're glad you're here man
it's important and that we're excited to
have you as our first guest here in
studio because my whole you know journey
with cash did you don't start at [ __ ]
when I came in here to do real a spot
guys yeah yeah Gomez and then you just
took all the [ __ ] every time I show
up from realest pocket-sized over like
10 of 11 he's like God we're gonna get
started twelve thirty five you might
want to call your wife and tell her
sorry
call your mother home for something yeah
you want a water why you disappoint your
parents some instant all right let's get
into a Tommy uh we know I know a good
amount of your backstory of how you grew
up just from hearing it through
conversation and through stand-up none
of it is really good as far as yeah you
weren't gonna be a senator let me know
to you that way no I tell us about how
you can vote put on these shorts tell us
about where you grew up how you grew up
the whole situation why I grew up in
Delaware County just like 20 minutes
outside of Philadelphia and blue collar
town lower-class
defense and he's looking at me like yeah
blue collar [ __ ] work it down when
you hate someone who's truly garbage
they defend that it's like pride it's
like yeah garbage thank you so much
I like how blue-collar we've always
that's not in that blue-collar you're
[ __ ] trash it's another way to say
trash yeah like I've been spending a lot
of time with my family I'm like in
Wildwood news they're out of here not
the north while look Gina yeah and I'm
just like oh you guys are very
blue-collar yeah yeah yeah punching
people on the beach I didn't know being
a receptionist at an orthodontist maybe
a blue-collar worker
[ __ ] skank who's feeling brenell's
loss for your scumbag kids grew up in a
row home oh yeah okay two bedrooms three
brothers so I'd stay in the same that's
the story bedroom with my one brother
slept in the same bed till he went to
college and Howard how far apart of you
two wait you guys didn't get your hands
on a set of bunk beds no my mother got a
bunk bed when he was like a junior in
college or junior in high school like
got upgraded to a bunk bed when we were
like I was like 16 and then you know you
have to laugh quietly jerking off you
guys still make the fort when you got to
finally get the bunk we're still gonna
swing from this thing right he went to
he went to Texas A&M and I finally got
my own room holy [ __ ] yeah well he got
kicked out after the first semester
thank you guys like you're fat you come
from
is it like you're trash clear trash but
like you're also you're very
good-looking you're very good at talk
like I feel like you can [ __ ] your
way into certain like you can achieve
things and then once you get to the
party it was like you're not allowed at
this party yeah and then you [ __ ] up
something yeah like I was making six
figures and I decided to start this
comedy [ __ ] exactly like you can
your way into something like you had to
scheme the whole time every job I've
ever gotten came from my charm at the
interview and then I didn't know what
the [ __ ] I'm just be lying my way
through the first three months of
talking a fire here's a good softball
player Tom it's just you know Cody wydo
come he's at the front of the class if
you open up your syllabus everybody what
are you talking about here I just
cheated off everyone in college at
Drexel and then I got positions and I
couldn't really get in the direction
that's pretty good Drexel is a good
school Pennsylvania yeah yeah we could
definitely take Tommy out to a [ __ ]
party at the Hamptons
[ __ ] roll up the pants a little bit
you know get a little khaki thing going
little Capri vibe you know put a mojito
on his hand and you wouldn't even know
yeah hey you got you acclimate very well
and you also you're the kind of trash
that like fancy people want to be around
cuz you're not like on by the looks of
it you're not very dangerous what do you
mean you want like face tattoos and like
you're not like what like what like so
people let you you know what I mean but
I see please from the wrong side of the
tracks then you end up like stealing the
silverware I really wants classy people
recognize that you're trash and you're
entertaining they want to pet you you're
your nominal because you're not gonna
bite us entertain us yes
used to [ __ ] banging his daughter
asking some cocktail waitress she knows
what I get anything baby blow in the
area
you know any party tees are already
Grindr
holy [ __ ] all right so what did I like
what did you pop do what did your mom do
my dad ran a union warehouse in South
Philly okay I've heard a few stories
yeah yeah and actually experience a
really interesting story where I was
like oh he's definitely he was somewhat
he had to deal with them I mean you're
you're supplying all the union's so at
some point so I come by looking for an
envelope Wow
I slept with this girl in college and I
parts I parked my car on on Walnut and
in the morning it got towed so I called
my daddy he worked at 18th and cherry
and I was like dad can you come can you
come get me I need help and he said why
and he wig the [ __ ] out he's like why
are you and I was like I'm on the corner
of 18-6 for you and I was like I'm all
he never talked to me like this before
he's like listen me stay there I'll call
you back in two minutes don't [ __ ]
move and I was like wow this dude is
pissed Jesus I get a call
he's like again where are you I'm like
dad I can't say it again 18th and cherry
is like listen to me right now
a man's gonna come pick you up you
should you sit in the back you shut your
[ __ ] mouth and don't say a word about
25 minutes later this Lincoln Town Car
rolls up and it was like so
stereotypical do you see the window come
down he's like are you Tommy
[ __ ] [ __ ] get in the car my dad's
got me so stiff because he never talked
about that's why I like sat in the car
and I tried to open the front door he
goes what the [ __ ] you don't get the
back and I was like okay the whole way
he's like adjust in the rearview mirror
well I three get in one watch it no he
was super nice and he was like he was
like I hope she was worth it and I was
like no I was just with friends and he's
like okay okay okay he takes me to
Lublin Lew Blum [ __ ] the Ron's Philly
yeah and I go I get out and I'm like
thank you so much for everything he's
like what he'd thrown away for you and
he waited for three [ __ ] hours handed
me an envelope to pay for it he says
don't tell your father gave me like 250
bucks to pay for it waited till I got
towed and it took me like 20 years to
ask my dad about this story and now as
he's getting older and he gets drunk in
the basement of Carlo where I'll see
he'll to start telling me like all these
[ __ ] stories like what about that one
guy Aaron okay weird right
at a pediatric he was one of nine kids
his dad left him when he was like 11
your dad yeah yeah the guy in the
Lincoln
yeah his family was trash all his you
know although all my uncles and aunts
have like missing teeth oh where were
they no Yadin yeah yeah not much better
yeah I can't say what that place looks
like myself that mother was one of 12
Irish Catholics from like that's a time
Amana
12:1 of 9 what dies [ __ ] yeah I got
hundreds of cousins I don't [ __ ] know
I met my wife cousin at McDonald's when
I was in high school she's like are you
Tom papa and I was like yeah she's a
kind of cousin catching me out
good-looking boy was on Thanksgiving all
right that's [ __ ] very good and you
went to Drexel mm-hmm were you good
student in high school yeah is ranked
12th really yeah at what slamming doors
in the lockers finger back in juniors
you were number 12 and you're it's not a
good school not senior Bonner high
school Catholic school in Drexel Hill
there's no like 250 300 people close to
your nose you got big [ __ ] this close
I don't know I've always had a small
nose it's Roman it's nice bulls are
kicking I didn't sign up for this guess
that you know but no Tommy's he his his
movements are classy like you know when
you posted during the beginning the
quarantine his girl first of all
beautiful smart charming absolutely
fantastic broad time we got the jeans oh
he showed up he showed a video of what
they were making for dinner he's got the
good knives he's making like [ __ ] a
Cebu ko he's making polenta
well did this all came through
quarantine because I get I get whiskey
blacked out and I just go on Amazon and
and buy I bought two couches store
cuz Gillis is my mom I got [ __ ]
upgrade everything I got two couches I
spent like six grand corn to one of the
kitchen that's where I play playstation
and find out if or how garbage Tommy is
now just a routine question inside we
know where you came from but do you
think you're garbage yeah yeah I
absolutely yeah there's no I mean no
wait you said I take you I take you guys
Nayla I think there's a way to be classy
garbage like you salon sure we also find
out too that like regardless of how good
you like how much you want to change and
like be better it's still in you you
know what I mean like you like you're
the kind of guy they'll get in the party
and then start a fight or whatever yeah
just can't totally you can reduce it to
HIV but you're always gonna work the
prep a little bit you know what I mean
holy [ __ ] all right couple of a couple
of basic questions we're gonna start off
with number one what was the name of the
street that you grew up on Chazz Wald Oh
Chazz well Rhodes has never even heard
that combination of letters what about a
fourth Street Main Street gotta get the
money to cheese ball that's free trashy
okay what grocery store did your mom
shot back growing up passmark Oh marks
are bad your shop right there was a - I
can be our [ __ ] garbage no shop rates
coffee okay really yes they can put back
like below shop right you might call it
a bad baggage on you money got a bad
shop right but Charlotte's overall you
know if marks are like [ __ ] I gotta
learn something that you can pay bills
at passport check and pay the bills
okay go let me see here you already said
the thing about the teeth I was gonna
ask you if you could say with confidence
if anybody is missing teeth you're not
missing any teeth right I had a root
canal during quarantine ah whereabouts
for back teeth that I have both halves
and I try and tell my doctor I'm like it
I think it's from getting hit in
football from cracking my teeth because
I don't want ailments from alcohol drug
use
I took a blindside hit I was 13 that's
what my teeth are falling out I played
what Ray Lewis you know real garbage
seeing four do like white trash Jews or
they get in the 20s is they have like
just the front like four yeah do they're
missing like a whole a whole chain gang
I'm missing two back here the story that
I go with is that in college I got hit
with a little cross ball a good deal
always go sports which is true but
[ __ ] it was on my ass
you know what happened was I had some
dental work done and just over time
those root canals don't last forever
yeah there's no lifetime guarantee on
yeah and all of a sudden my [ __ ] two
started killing me and this was right
when I started comedy in Philly so I had
no money but my mom is friends with this
oral how did you say that when you start
a comedy you had no money you also still
have no my mom was good friends with
this oral surgeon who kept his
motorcycle in our garage oh wait a
minute so she was [ __ ] surgeon is he
that he can't spring for the 25 bucks a
month yeah he's gotta drop it you're
dealing with a friend do you see what
he's doing
listen what you just said he's an oral
surgeon parking his motorcycle in your
mom's garage pretty classy tonight it
wasn't a [ __ ] dirt bike it was a
Harley what van did he work out but he
all he would he pulled them for me and I
just go in Nate poem for free cotton
dropped me off one time I'm just getting
the [ __ ] talking the joint I'll pull
your tooth ask him to put one in that's
another thing dude was any of your
dentist or orthodontist or anything at
any point was there any office in their
house there was one guy yes I go to his
crib he made his house my maid the guy
who gave me my orthodontist
he in a corner house they look kind of
like a rancher and made it into an
office and he has like a one-bedroom up
top yeah that's always the only only
decent orthodontist can pull that off
yeah you can't go to like a hairstylist
you can't go to a pediatrician in his
[ __ ] basement you know Mel dinner
cooking yeah I used to get my hair cut
my buddy uh Jeff Rooney is his mom
Tootsie had a baseball and that's where
her hair room just had one wall mural my
display she's nice so long that's like a
[ __ ] 4-foot mirror what does that
vidal sassoon funny alright so this is
what I wanted to ask you um when was the
last time you ate a meal outside under
an awning Oh probably when I was 25 hmm
wow that's pretty good yeah it's really
good Wow and it's only because I go back
home to my buddy's parents house and
only a few of my trash bag friends still
associate with their old parents house
most of the parents move out right
eventually when they go to college so
like his parents still have like this
yeah you get that nostalgic eating some
[ __ ] hot dog charcoal grill where's
the gas Bernie's um growing up did your
mom make cresent dinner roll of course I
actually first of all I had them last
month they are [ __ ] it's so [ __ ]
incredible they're so good
everyone like pre-butter ders yeah it's
like big fan [ __ ] go time oh the
endorphin release when that thing pops
holy [ __ ] twist tonight come on you
ain't gonna [ __ ] for a week but it's
gonna be worth it my mom would try to
clasp you put them in like a basket with
like a [ __ ] trash but I'm gonna eat
them yeah I hate when they I hate when
they bake with that with like somebody's
mom'll use like that for baking maybe
like oh my god this desserts
unbelievable and they're like yeah you
just take some Pillsbury rolls and a
little stove top stuffing and you put it
down with a little cinnamon and sugar
it's Sampat like the only pigs in a
blanket I enjoyed it
wrapped around a crescent roll dude 100
[ __ ] percent but then they crazy and
put a hot awful the blanket through the
[ __ ] napkin looks like an oil slick
God go ahead Kip anyone in your family
ever order a ShamWow No thank God no
it's what about the chopper never had a
chopper we were always a hands-on kind
of family did you guys wear they order
anything because that's like that might
as well be like playing with the devil
in might I felt like that was a classic
thing to do I now I get older I realized
that it would that is garbage because I
do it but uh
ordering like it something like QVC and
all that kind of [ __ ] I thought that
like my parents couldn't afford that
that's it jewelry and [ __ ] we're so
trashy that my mom was like you never
trust it if you can't get it guy you're
not giving over your phone you know who
you're talking to
like they're not real pearls yeah do you
got you guys any pets growing up were
you a pet family yeah we a pug yeah
that's pretty good for like [ __ ] 37
years till like one I was wonky like
Bill Cosby there's things those things
fall apart quickly oh my god hey bust at
the seams that much they start losing
the joint you like cool Buffy's only
gonna have like three more months okay
like go in the backyard when it's not
full with [ __ ] yeah she left it like ten
more years dude I got a question where
did you bury the dog
100% Arlington Cemetery was beautiful if
you don't think there's a couple of
Rusty's in my mom's backyard was my
mother like got in a fight with my
father about it because my dad had we we
grew like peppers and tomatoes and stuff
oh yeah it was as big as you're gonna
ruin the eggplant the backyard was as
big as the studio's tight bank runs its
eyes are all [ __ ] up the yard was
plans and then one we'd one corner for
like Buffy's remains we go down like
five only five feet to bury my days we
hit the main hang around with [ __ ]
dude telco retards in Philly repainted
second immediately I'm like yeah let's
[ __ ] went through the second I cross
street Road in Bucks County again what
are you doing later paddywhacks do
dollar you call it day that barring a
dog in the backyard a dog as deep as you
buries you and it's so much he ain't
never get mad huh still had three feet
do you guys do the thing we in there
ain't happy I'm dating that much did you
guys like cut his fingernails off and
[ __ ] like that so you couldn't identify
two houses down no so what I wanted to
know is growing up did you have any
blankets that had dogs on them oh my
kind of course trash plates with dogs on
it was either sports or or dog doo-doo
supports blank the sports blankets with
dog hair or dog they were never watched
this morning I guess or never watch
that's a number one indicator for
garbage people you just look and see how
much pet hairs on the back of their
country I can't I can't that's a way I
said oh it's gross right this is true
cuz garbage people like my parents
worked so hard to fake everybody out
like you were saying earlier my mom was
like pristine about that [ __ ] if you had
like any kind of dog hair on you look
for you can't you walk out you look poor
people will fight tooth and nail to not
look as poor as their own course and one
of those things is [ __ ] a roll on the
back of your [ __ ] winter coat get the
little boy got hippie have you ever
jumped off a trampoline into a pool of
course of course that's like a
white-trash waterpark that was the big
thing for my buddies
yeah he had a hit a big trampoline he
put in between the deck and the pool one
you can go right over cuz he didn't have
a railing at the time because of us
wasn't exactly up to code
did you how many times I drug a [ __ ]
trampling to the side of the pole just
like there's like no padding anywhere
and then after the first time it gets
wet and like you lose your traction you
kids are losing teeth [ __ ] breaking
orbitals I mean a good look man I don't
know I keep saying ah man but I do have
you ever eaten at a bar that was
connected to a motel yes I mean a
wedding a wedding does that count
there's like a sprint of hotel like a
country club type I'm not talking about
[ __ ] happen 90 I'm talking about
[ __ ] going into buffet at the [ __ ]
Shady stabby motel that as a bar
connected to it I'm gonna say nose one
neon beer sign for paps out front I'll
go no windows I'm gonna say no to that
bit but I don't I don't know I feel like
when you go to shapes you have how about
the Red Roof Inn on the on Route one
I guess that's tough yeah a red roof
that has a restaurant next to it and I
did it in Siegfried and Roy Halloween
costume how were the oysters but no I'm
gonna say no to that I don't think I
have have you ever swam in the pool of a
motel of course yeah yeah come on I know
she's gonna piss did a bull of a motel
we just did one last summer in Delaware
a motel pool where it's like the
l-shaped motel pool no why wouldn't
worthwhile with us I love it shell Motel
Carona no somebody else shows up you
feel like a rich guy yeah yes is mine
your backstroke and there's [ __ ]
weird kids on the second floor looking
at all the rich kids had houses down the
shore we would just we'd rent like one
week at a motel and the pool man you
felt you felt like you were wealthy
you're right yeah and you live here now
a top plate would smell like chlorine
for like three days God because there's
a burn all the fun but I got a game here
yesterday on the beach in one of those
motels that AC gets [ __ ] better dude
bone chilling comb the shitty or the
motel it better the better the first
thing I do
there's no filters in that look because
trash people will go [ __ ] it's the first
thing I do when I walk into a hotel I
got right over [ __ ] oh wait a fifth
right here for the remote out the window
cuz I ain't changing that first [ __ ]
number could go to three I'm I do that
and I constantly leave the TV on just so
people think that there's always
somebody in the room also I see some
[ __ ] poor person trash I got nothing
to steal but I don't want them coming in
looking around you ever get pissed off
like if someone's a dick when you check
in I'll run the [ __ ] water I'll just
like you know what [ __ ] this guy yeah I
put the shower on TV on I'll leave it
all on fro like 20 minutes because in
your [ __ ] poor trash head you like
that's what I look that's 50 cents like
cuz you weren't allowed to do that you
weren't a lot of [ __ ] let the DB only
be a lot and that the front desk guy is
gonna pay for it make that SH man [ __ ]
you so now you're 725 an hour NY gets a
bike ride home it's summertime gang it's
hot and sweaty out there
that's why you need sheath yeah you know
what I'm sayin
yeah a fabric has a silky feel to it and
it keeps everything comfortable and in
place let me explain something all right
I I'm a bigger guy alright I go to
Walmart I get my underwear they only
last [ __ ] a couple of days I don't
even make it out of the store get
yourself some sheep I'm eating them
before I walk out but they're terrible
all right and here's what makes shieff
unique alright here's what makes sheathe
unique it's got a pouch okay keep your
dick and your balls separated especially
in the summertime because that creates
heat he creates moisture moisture
creates rash rash creates scratch then
your [ __ ] fingers are thinking and
everybody's [ __ ] looking at yet to
pull so keep it tight listen now some of
you might not want your dick and balls
separated and listen if that's the case
I don't know if I were man enough I want
to be friends with you but I gotta tell
you they sent me a pair of these bad
boys and I'm [ __ ] swimming in I got
room for Foley if he wants to join park
the car in there get some little guy
sizes more of a genetic disorder I think
for the folks in the middle of a bell
curve you know what I mean yeah I
recommend dude I highly recommended they
sent us some and they're [ __ ] great
you can wear it like any other boxer it
doesn't matter it's just [ __ ] crazy
comfortable and one more thing
these look good if you're looking for
someone to take a sexy picture maybe
send a lucky lady and you're like hmm
big man put on your sexy drawers and get
the snapping I did I literally call them
I call them my wife I call my sexy
underwear because I got one pair of them
and I gotta watch them every day cuz I
roll the quarters in here hi so listen
so go to sheath underwear dot-com to get
a pair of smart underwear and if you use
code garbage that's G a r be a GE just
like you garbage you'll get 20 percent
off your order
20 military discount let the big man wet
his beat time 20 percent come on that's
awesome who's running the numbers
already they're gonna be belly-up but
hey they said it who owns that puffy
[ __ ] away
sheathe underwear calm use promo code
garbage today Tommy have you ever been
involved in a belly flop contest yeah I
mean as a kid you'd have to be probably
the question would be like what age yeah
sick at 13 probably stop there yeah stop
around 13 good we should do it off a
trestle
that's real garbage yet we had at
Russell - Rita yeah trolley tracks in
the backyard like the backyard went like
here and then there was Charlie tracks
behind it if you went down like a mile
it had like a 20 30 foot trestle that we
would you jump off and it'll be a little
pit that you would have you had a hit
like a 6x6 yeah and then there'd be like
a [ __ ] car tire license plate and
bike parts and if you didn't hit a
little edge dude we used to step into a
quarry growing yeah so I'm looking back
on it's like what the [ __ ] you think
crazy but I have a follow-up question to
that what are the the two proper ways to
jump into an above-ground pool
I'm looking for two moves like this or
this I go wild and then cannibal in okay
full extension dancer is either a
cannonball or the European cousin the
cannibal oh yes the older kids did it
yes little kids with the sailors died
yeah it takes guts
the first one it's like you know your
Adrenaline's up there it takes guts to
dive into a [ __ ] above-ground pool
Holly darling two feet deep this goes
wrong it's got a nice house
all right this is the thing we did and
some people had tweeted at me because no
guest has answered this correctly or has
agreed with me
did you guys ever like grease a
watermelon and play like you try to get
a [ __ ] this is how tragic we used to go
to the [ __ ] Swim Club and it would
they would get like 20 people on each
team oh I know you're saying you grease
the watermelon throw it in the middle
and you hey was a flick the egg toss
kind of thing know how to swim that you
had to get it across was like rugby
yeah and that's to the egg toss you
don't eat the eggs great stop watermelon
you don't eat the rind you're not an
animal you're still holding it it's been
in chlorine and chlorine never Seema
that's some hillbilly [ __ ] I'll tell you
right now you sit down hiding that bone
and now eat it
who wants to place it on the watermelon
[Laughter]
that is trash how did you guys have did
you have to entranceways of the house of
course for you a front door person or a
side door we never we never locked the
doors typically and then at one point we
just started climbing in the side when
my mom decided she started locking the
door because the neighborhood got bad so
we have to stack the wood on the side of
the house and and break the window up
and climb through the old wooden window
[ __ ] Joe Pesci front back straight
through a ropes don't have size exactly
the back it's like a long skinny alley
did the truck did the train actually run
on those tally tracks or was itwas Act
expired I can't sleep without a fan on
because or like if I go somewhere quiet
I can't fall asleep because I'm used to
that ding-ding-ding meaning meaning my
[ __ ] I have three different sounds
tell machine I wonder where that's gone
for on Zillow right now Jesus why I had
two questions
did anyone who done did it currently or
at any point any family members uncles
or anybody ever owned a convertible my
dad had a El Camino for a while
do you ride the back of that to the keys
no he says he had it or he wanted one I
I think he said he had one in college
and that's the new [ __ ] came along
dreams he had three el Caminos could
take it from him but uh yeah that's the
one car that's like the trash car I
always want it because my dad let me
know they're cool too it's like a
novelty it's old-school yeah I think
like convertibles can be nice right
depending on the car like my we had it
we grew up with car learn how to driving
was a Sebring Convertible which is like
just dead giveaway you're [ __ ] trash
yeah none has let my hair down well I
only got 19 grand the majority of this
country is dog [ __ ] because they like
the most popular rental cars are like a
convertible or like a Mustang yeah
Mustang convertible at that one any time
you go on vacation like I went to like
Florida for like Spring Break like
yellow Mustang it's always some real
shitty going we're getting a Mustang in
an imported beer like a Korres ah
my dad's buddy had an El Camino growing
up yeah and it was weird because he had
a family of four and that was that was
their main foundation I remembered a
softball game I saw them all jumping in
I was like where the kids going they
jumped in the [ __ ] back that's a real
piece of [ __ ] to SPCA dogs you don't
have to feel like the pressure of
utilizing the trunk sure you know if you
get like a big [ __ ] SUV or a big
pickup truck you got to be like I
need is for something how come you like
a six-pack of beer just bouncing around
like [ __ ] bowling balls did any of
her cars growing up have wood paneling
yes of course we have a Chrysler LeBaron
pop had a little bit of money here
talking about hey Myron that's French I
think a championship game for our drexel
raiders we we had to put like you know
go Raiders and all that [ __ ] on the side
and my brother he's a permanent marker
so it it was a blue Chrysler LeBaron
with wood paneling that had permanent
permanently go graders all over know
what's gonna get painted man what are
you nuts
yeah I mean he was a coach so I guess it
[Laughter]
just to stay on cars here a little bit
when you guys would go on vacation or
something like that and you guys were
taking the car would you do multiple
cars for the whole family like for the
like with the cousins and [ __ ] where
you'd all would follow each other
cousins too much you know we when we
want a vacation was me and my two
brothers and my my parents and I would
sit [ __ ] and ride it up to like the
Poconos we go we go you can't all fit in
the motel we'd rent a house in a Lake
Wallenpaupack oh nice now that I thought
was like I was like yeah my parents are
saving up this year and I I went to the
cabin like three years ago
holy [ __ ] doll yeah it's so small it's
like it's like a natural wood like it
was made by someone's hands a real
actual cabin and I was like man this is
get so close to a lake my dad is [ __ ]
raking it in this year balloons guys
getting their cars though they came with
like a like a little motorboat to go
fishing aha do it we'll go three miles
an hour like against the wind and you're
like sissies we have a boat or an angler
I like it huh
what is the who's your current self self
cellphone provider
82
that's pretty good not bad yeah what
it's what do you think the yeah I mean
obviously cricket is the lowest [ __ ]
chance
he's got sprint I got spring oh that's -
I would go cricket splenic Verizon ATP
mobiles shitty - and mobiles right after
Sprint yes t-mobile yes yes oh [ __ ] you
I know buddy people people that so like
they're like no I don't have sprung up
like grandfathering cuz I sign a bunch
of contracts when I was 15 Oh like 30
bucks yeah don't they start slowing down
your speed hey it's Tuesday we're
cranking you down starting to get your
porn like the old school days like one
line play with you a little bit someone
slow kippie now hey if we through beaten
off you gotta go to your own memory bank
I don't mind that play in the classics
you know all right what do you got big
guy what do I got
was the last time use a corn star
machine coin star yes Jesus Christ this
I would say TD bank days before they got
rid of them not very classy and what
about do you get cash back when you make
a purchase always 20 bucks these 20
bucks my seat is up I won first place in
town yeah most places only have ten they
could be a twenty always no fee I know
that's that's the trash that's why
you're garbage
what my TV pack is like a mile walk so
like accumulate through a seat town I
get like 200 bucks
what the [ __ ] that's real bad get the
cash back that's trash dude I must use
coins star I went down I went down them
they don't exist anymore right cuz I got
other stars dude I hear they're not in
the city though there's like two in the
city and you go to those supermarkets
and they ain't good yes Papa had to go
to the Bronx to cash in like 60 bucks a
couple of years ago it was not fun yeah
easy 40-minute line to get to 15 pennies
I almost took a thinking change down two
bucks this weekend cuz this is just like
in my cabinet and like I knew I'm like
I'm a part of me I was I was lying to
myself cause I'm like well it's not a
coin store up here I'll take it down
there and do it I'm like I'm about to
move [ __ ] 40 bucks over state lines
do they get
i individually-wrapped about yeah
recently 40 40 bucks and change like
because the TD Bank was like listen that
this machine doesn't work anymore I'm
like oh I got this big barrel thing a
change what do I do and she said well we
can give you free trip together
[Laughter]
apologize your dad and I wrapped like
like 35 bucks
and in those things just to give it to
the bank I was ahead what the [ __ ] we're
gonna do it keep collecting the [ __ ] so
I can't carry it if I saw you in a TD
Bank private desks on the side I just
doing blowing rolling points
show me your coin counting room please
have you paid anything with a money
order recently no it's been years but I
paid I used to I just pay my rent for
the money what did you I don't have
checks why I'll try I just don't have
checks why don't you check it takes
[ __ ] 20 minutes no because I opened
up my dive TDS is a big thing TD banks a
touchdown bank I got uh Mike I started
my account in Pennsylvania and now I
live in New York so what they've New
York says you have to go to Pennsylvania
branch to order checks you don't go home
anymore
yeah I do I'm like drunk with my [ __ ]
knucklehead friends you know Jesus
Christ some money order what do you got
we gotta go for that post office it's a
power 95 yeah [ __ ] thank you and when
you have to do like the whole
explanation about your banking situation
yeah I'm first of all P I TD banks are
one every corner liquor store yeah
that's who I'm trash man I'm a credit
union man oh shut up - maybe federal
that's a garbage thing - oh really does
it even more way more reason that we're
not gonna get into for legal purposes
that's why is that Navy Federal white
trash people think they're getting more
- credit union one percent over two
years what's a couple years ago I took
out a pretty sizable loan with zero
collateral they're like a drunken
[ __ ] cut you junior glorified
mattress - oh great
yeah they don't give a [ __ ] if they know
you from a dart league - like he's worth
it I seen Tommy Billy Sonny's and I've
been a member for 26 years agos my dad
stopped
the account when I was a little kid
there's been like three bucks in there
my whole life
I'd like treat me like I would love to
see them at the wrong time at night all
the years that I've known you just go oh
yeah I remember oh wait oh wait was it
big 103 I am trying to get my eyes how
much money you got extended well
technically it is the next day remember
when I had something hitting my account
and I asked I was on the phone with like
whoever it was con at it whatever Ali
and I had so little money in my account
but a check was gonna clear at some
point that day that I had to ask them do
you know what time you're spending the
plates to get a couple of minutes on a
direct deposit a coffee at me [ __ ]
before you make this back do one time
with what he was all you know you were
all boozed up or whatever and you were
likely he had like 400 bucks or
something and he goes hold this Haley
just picked up his tips when we first
moved to New York and now we're not
party and you know yeah of course and
he's like he gave me he had four he had
four hundred bucks he kept two hundred
he's like this will be a cab it's a
couple of beers breakfast in the morning
you hold the two hundred under no
circumstance do you give it back to me
not one circumstance you ever get was my
credit union be federal I'm not [ __ ]
around with in like out of a bad movie
yeah yeah he like gets a beer and turns
his I gonna get that money I'm headed
out of here I'm oh yeah giving you the
money man come on dude it end of him
give my [ __ ] money man I'm not
[ __ ] around come on [ __ ] the money
cuz you already called the dealer he's
gonna barish me in front of my people
those IPAs man I'm telling you you get a
couple of those in here
you start with one you're like never
again I I'm not doing drugs for another
year you get two beers and you're like
wow Jeff's number yeah three beers
you're like technically the calendar
year
I follow the Mayan calendar Kevin what
do you got let's see laughter this
dirtbag growing up I'm assuming this as
a no but did you have HBO or any other
premium channel no we did not
we got prism right before I went to
college no for hockey okay eyes for the
Flyers yeah playoff hockey I think Perez
Oh madam it was like was there a key for
this
was there any hope like was there a
scramble situation where there's a
switch in the spice spice was big yeah
that was all we had was the the box up
top you go to what was it 98 or scramble
you set the way for that that's why I
can beat off within 30 seconds yeah the
spice workout now my dad was uh we
always wanted hpoes 4hb over years all
you wanna do I was like a big deal but I
think it was like 25 bucks a month back
then with you which is paper yeah yeah
that's like 90s 25 but once a prism was
like the the Sprint I feel like prison
was like a local operation wasn't it was
I don't know Pennsylvania I mean it
definitely wasn't [ __ ] national yeah
no no way but it was considered premium
they had movies that you their
blockbuster yeah you just go right to
prison just wait til back to the future
I remember that summer yeah I watched 48
hours like 500 times it was a little kid
way too young they used to only play
like each channel would get like three
movies in three months and they would
just back-to-back [ __ ] Roger Rabbit
do we at one point we never had it ever
and then at one point in college or not
even cotton-like high school I was
welcomed by my parents bedroom I heard
like Star Wars or something I'm like
yeah that's weird I go downstairs I go
it's on TV so I start flicking here
these [ __ ] scumbags only one TV only
on TV I'm like yes bring in the whole
house lines it's better I love it I'm
not giving it up on the screen you must
have did some [ __ ] that I said what the
[ __ ] it was my stepdad he's like [ __ ]
Denis Leary from the Sandlot
that ain't even [ __ ] cold don't touch
my root beer yeah that's some [ __ ]
tell me how do you feel about imitation
crab I'm okay with it I hate to say this
I mean if you've done if done in like a
cake there's a Red Roof cake yeah you
gotta hide it you can't put it like what
and I know this guy's got a cookie puss
in crappy [ __ ] kind of [ __ ] up
birthdays are you guys happen no I think
you can like you know it's it's
obviously garbage food but you can hide
it well if you if you do it right sure
but very an imitation crabmeat
eat it out of the back with a crab cake
little tartar sauce tomato right what
were your birthdays like growing up
remember anyone specifically yeah
another few pictures I posted last
couple years like they're just all what
do you think your home going through
Polaroids during the pandemic yeah I had
a very emotional breakdown yeah
touch-and-go there for a while no there
were just like you my mother put up
bowls or like chips and pretzels all the
attention was on the cake not the dinner
itself just rentals at a kid party
that's it
all the uncles are smoking there's like
a you can barely see the kids you can
barely make out their faces just smoke
and there's like babies on laps babies
on laughs is a big I don't give up and
all the uncles are just smoking beers as
Miller High Life Saul over the counters
never about the kid that was the drink
Miller High Life yeah that's the best
pop here man it tastes like a fruit
roll-up remember your uncle's your dad's
like when you were closer than that beer
breath smoke they'd be a mint it may be
a valid mentors before popping it
getting in the car let me sober up a bit
dude would you drinking and driving in
the 90s was why don't you dick that's
all you did cuz you knew the cop somehow
through a softball league or some [ __ ]
but no even the parents a lot of
warnings if a kid had a birthday it was
just an excuse to get all the uncles and
aunts you're [ __ ] a hammer yes I mean
if I go to a birthday now for somebody
I'm not going for the kid Yeah right
go for my [ __ ] sister's beers yeah
would your mom make the cake or would it
be purchase oh man never never purchase
never got the cookie one from the mall
nope she would get the boxes
you know that vanilla or chocolate spray
if she wanted to get fancy she would put
it in a long-form pan like the thirteen
and a half by nine and then she'll put
both mixes and then do that that
toothpick swirl the marble cake that's
that's how my mom showed off to like all
the answers okay she would make this
this threat or the icing where it was
cool with but then she put in pudding
mix so it was like a light chocolate
[ __ ] broke out Cool Whip [ __ ]
frosting [ __ ] Betty Crocker I'm out
buttercream were you guys a Bagel Bites
or pizza rolls fan people bites hundred
percent class because rolls are trash
dude I think I had pizza rolls once
aristocratic yeah they're good Bagel
Bites 100% bangle bites you can't dude a
good a nice little out what did you cook
them in toaster oven microwave or oven
we go oven I know that's classy because
garbage he's making his [ __ ] night
lights in and I'm gonna have a toaster
oven
I thought toaster ovens were classy I
did he thinks they're trash no have one
they're classy lovely first of all you
need the counter space cuz you have a
microwave she's gonna need a real estate
yes it's a problem sink you got a sink a
microwave now you're looking at what
like a foot and a half got the coffee
pot a coffee pot microwatts a foot now
you look into if you just squeeze a jet
in there you gotta have the perfect wait
wait how about you growing up where was
your microwave no yours was sitting on
the counter was it was your hyung hyung
jeez yes well that's well no mine was in
the wall not on the counter counter oh I
was a can eight hours on the table the
centerpiece at dinner for the first
first microwave that we got it was like
[ __ ] Christmas 1986 alright we were
living in a townhouse did you bury the
backyard when it died where that
microwave full weighs 125 pounds now you
gotta get a v-neck to get her life
later yeah for three years this t-shirt
had zippers my dad never got a big bonus
or something that year but just like you
we didn't have the counter space for it
but he got a [ __ ] monster
yeah huge dude did you microwave have a
rack that yeah not my buddy's my buddy's
mom had a wrap big one that had a middle
rack you put like a lasagna pop
generational test but when ours was
hanging off the counter so much that you
had the legs you know as little pegs on
it they were hanging what do you got big
man what do I got here we talked about
the pets the money orders did you have a
bug zapper
yeah a family bug zapper out back my
house know how bad no once my dad got a
he made it he built the own his own deck
our own back deck any that's he had like
protect mm-hmm so once we could hang out
there and sit on something we got this a
purr and we loved it is that deck still
there I don't know I haven't been back
to the house in like ten years
what do you mean though they moved they
moved when I went to college where'd
they go how could a creep around the
backside given your decking cry you guys
got spice good jerk off in the basement
just have a shovel I want to dig the dog
up real quick let's see let's see let's
see
have you ever taken one of those
old-timey photos on the boardwalk no no
that again I thought it was pretty well
I thought that was wealthy like ya need
money to save up and plus my friends
were just too embarrassed
yeah you mean with a family or friends
warranty maybe we were talk
Florentine about anybody is doing I was
always embarrassed because people waited
and watched you and I was like nah yeah
I can't get the costume I was you know
you never looked the way you thought you
know you were gonna look cool you'll get
a [ __ ] idiot well you're wearing a
one size fits all [ __ ] tuxedo you
look like a jerk-off also your [ __ ]
you grow up with people busting your
balls if you feel any kind of confidence
in staying still it's [ __ ] by now
freaky just wait around in front of
strangers holding up some [ __ ] fake
Tom anyone in your family ever play
semi-pro football no also it's not real
when you hear semi-pro like semi-pro
baseball is another thing I had up like
a bunch of friends that were in that
like all this is like fastpitch wood
League it's like such [ __ ] like that
semi-pro be my dad would talk about a
semi-pro back when I was playing
semi-pro broke my know I'm like oh my
gosh yeah no bro wouldn't close the
yearbook after work in front of the
[Laughter]
[ __ ] football that was our home field
I remember watching the dude you get
smoked into the [ __ ] dirt and you
just have like you know just give opened
up the bases are still there trippin
he's broken Heinicke bottles everywhere
any campaign signs on the lawn no [ __ ]
no no my dad take that they were uh they
kept that [ __ ] real quiet
I get me because of his job sure yeah I
got a I got a play close to the best I
know
knew who he was like voting for we
weren't a very political loud family so
we were just loud talking politics what
about the long decorations what was the
story mother didn't do that either she
thought that was garbage yeah like
people put up like happy Valentine's Day
just like Peggy knows like for sale sign
decorations that yeah she always [ __ ] on
people that would like decorate the
inside of windows for like the holidays
like it right and happy holidays on the
front front glassier door she's like
never oh what'd she do for Christmas
what was this everything was decorated
inside we would put lights up colored
lights we were colored like color white
people are bad christmas tree with all
white tree all white lights I'm like
that's [ __ ] that's that's like
wealthy elegant weird like pounds of
tinsel colored lights everywhere
what color was it was it a real trigger
fake tree real tree my dad was intense
about that was like one of our and then
walk through no you could just go like
you know there's open farms where you
just cut that yeah yeah wait so you're
telling me I walk by your house
Christmas Eve I can't tell who lives
there I don't know it's not no Christmas
at all on the outside outside yeah my
dad would spend yeah but that was like a
big thing we put lights on along the
railing but all colored I'll colored Wow
yeah well now I feel like when I see
colored lights on my car you wanna have
a warm beer and a cigarette and not get
what you wanted for Christmas yes now my
tree when I get a tree every year and I
put up white lights cuz that's why I
always wanted to be yeah well a lot of
times Italians do Christmas real bad
yeah they're cardies [ __ ] yeah it's like
the red tree [ __ ] you're like fishes
though you do the Seven Fishes on every
one full deck oh yeah doesn't seem like
Italian if they seems like bricklayer
his Grandmama's first-generation [ __ ] a
wooden leg
I found out our gear imma what the [ __ ]
I was just about to say but now we never
we weren't like super yeah did you guys
you guys can really miss on [ __ ]
Christmas we would have the most Italian
thing is we always had a ham and lasagna
that kind of thing
yeah there was always a there was always
a lasagna or like a rigatoni or
something with every [ __ ] meal dude
we're big ham people and then use the
bone to make soup that was awesome yeah
get a nice hand over the pineapple in
the cherry all right only got one more
do you I don't know if you do I don't
know this question at all about you do
you or anybody in your family have calf
tattoo my brother had a calf got to it
was so racially insensitive and out of
my neighborhood it no longer exists
thank God yeah he was um I don't know if
I should talk about this but uh this is
the brother you lived with in the room
know my other brother but uh he was
recruited by by very a bad group Jesus
Delaware yeah
and he had like a business card on his
on his dresser it said racial purity is
America's security and I never forgot
that with my buddy my buddy Kuchar
because my brother's room was where
you'd go to like find like knives and
pee and he was [ __ ] off the rail in
certain literature so for like three
years he was like [ __ ] crazy
the vents straighten him out that he get
did he yeah yeah it's just a [ __ ]
Punk that was like you know hanging out
with the wrong group of hammers and he
had a tattoo on the on his back of his
calf that was a skull with a motorcycle
hat meanwhile he's driving like a
mongoose and underneath the skull was a
confederate flag
tied like a [ __ ] behind the neck so
it wasn't a du Pont's that recruited us
yes oh we need to get it like lasered
off like you don't even adult whole
technology came out he went there like
four or five sessions of that [ __ ] cuz
he was disgusting got my cap off yeah
anyways it's comedy guys that was so
show that you are garbage yeah but it's
perfect I think I got one more question
I should I got two more questions for
you some some couple more staples just
to finish it off and this will be able
to get a little sense of what you're
like now one do you ever as an adult
drink milk with dinner
no let's discuss thank you yeah if I see
I actually unfriended a Duke who used to
drink one in like an old roommate that
could come around well there we ate with
pasta he would yeah the most disgusting
[ __ ] thing and it's roots it doesn't
even mix that's the go-to all the ass a
pasta and milk right away fantastical
good [ __ ] trash no acid in fact does
it's it you shouldn't do that to your
balance it in fact will you Jack LaLanne
god damned that's that's a that's a
serious sickness you have yeah it's
called fatness yeah
tell you what I still got my ice cold
whole milk that I ain't got before I
pour it no I don't buy I don't buy milk
and I'll [ __ ] with milk yeah you keep
the ketchup in the fridge yeah keep the
syrup in the Cabret we don't do syrup no
I don't you mean mr. fancy pants with
your Klan brother in the diverse part of
this country we keep the syrup in the
[ __ ] cabinet like a gentleman no I
would [ __ ] with in it with an eggo
though I haven't had one I should get
stuck in that [ __ ] thing home style
didn't matter
keep them coming oh that's great holy
[ __ ] Tommy Pope hippy trash I mean no
one no two ways about from beginning to
end [ __ ] trash I'm different now if I
didn't have the it if I was on the fence
the brother man holy [ __ ]
American history why okay
he's a good kid you're a good kid Tommy
thank you buddy I love you very much
thank you absolute garbage but the best
kind of garbage there is I don't care
who you are
Tommy Pope went to your high school he's
the coolest [ __ ] guy in the school
off the [ __ ] jump I'll tell you that
right now
and the 12th smartest problem anything
you want the gang out there to know
before we get out of here no my real
name isn't Tommy always stay in the
[ __ ] shadows guys that's what you do
Kippy what do you got for the folks at
Cameron comedy on all social media and
if you're new to gasps digital please
and you're looking to sign up you get
you know HD livestream the chat yes
access to the whole network's library of
shows you can sign up use code a yg and
get a dollar-fifty off a month and
that's four you know as long as you keep
your subscription and we went our beak a
little bit you know what I mean it's
right now and we want to shout out to
everybody that's watching on the
livestream right now everybody that's in
the chat you know we'll keep it that
thing and get everybody involved we
couldn't be more happier here at gasps
digital we want to thank our producer
Dylan of course Bobby the hutch Louis
Ralph everybody here at the gasps
digital family Shannon we really
appreciate it and we will see you guys
next time right here on our you garbage
later Thank You Tommy thanks buddy